And let's go to our caller from the 9 7 3
area code who's calling today from 9 7 3.
Hello.
Yes, that's you, and please keep the phone
a little further from your mouth.
You're just coming in so loud.
This is better, that's much better.
Thank you.
OK.
But remember, I called less.
I called a couple weeks ago.
But then the phone calls.
The phones hardly crash and I never really
saw it.
You never I never got an answer to my question.
OK.
The question I was asking for is.
I was curious as to.
Like why?
In a hypothetical scenario as to why Bernie,
who did well in Michigan in 2016, for example,
lost Michigan horrendously in 2020, and I
said a theory was one that George Orwell had
just described in his book, The Road to Wigan
Pier, where he said that while though everyone
ought to be a socialist, the reason why working
class people turned away from socialism is
because it attracts it attracts what he described
cranks, you know, people who like we describe
them as like, you know.
Sandal wearing tweed.
You know that you can't really describe them
as like vegetarian nudist feminists in his
own words.
And I kind of wonder, do you think that like
in 2020, that progressive movement ignored
and what Orwell's warnings in the book and
paid the consequences of it?
I'm not familiar with that Orwell quote.
But listen, if you look at any of my post-mortems
on what happened to Bernie.
There is no question that the language of
revolution.
The not simply saying, hey, listen, guys,
I'm a social Democrat, not a Democratic socialist.
Social democracy is a regulated form of capitalism.
I don't think that the democratic socialist
label helped.
I think some of the people around him didn't
help.
So, yeah, I mean I it in I essentially completely
agree with what you're quoting to me from
George Orwell and every postmortem I've done
of why Bernie lost and lost badly.
I mean, I know people say, you know, you can't
look at the vote totals now because Bernie
dropped out a little while ago.
Biden was up by almost 2 million votes while
Bernie was still fully running the campaign.
It was not a small victory for Biden.
And I think all the things you're alluding
to via the George Orwell quote are 100 percent
in line with my analysis.
Also curious what your thoughts are on this
failed invasion of Venezuela, since I didn't
hear anything of it unless you mentioned it
on the Boenish.
I don't know much about it.
I know that there were some I don't even know
what to call them mercenaries.
I guess they would be called.
And there were allegations that they were
associated somehow with the Trump administration.
Although every every source for that was was
sort of different versions of propaganda,
state media that were saying that.
So I don't.
I'm still researching that.
I've not taken a position one way or the other
on it.
I mean, obviously, I'm against any coup in
Venezuela that the U.S. is involved in to
just get that on the record.
What I mean is I don't know enough about that
situation to comment intelligently right now.
OK.
All right, my friend, thank you so much for
the call.
Great to hear from you.